[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen wenn das stimmt wäre es
ein potenzielles Kriegsverbrechen das
sagte die damalige Sprecherin von
US-Präsident beiden fünf Tage nach dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine es
ging damals um den vermuteten Einsatz
von Streumunition mittlerweile ist klar
Russland setzt solche Streumunition in
großem Stil ein auch die Ukraine nutzt
sie und jetzt wollen die USA große
Mengen davon in die Ukraine liefern von
einer Waffe wohlgemerkt die in vielen
Ländern weltweit geächtet ist weil ihre
unzähligen Blindgänger verheerende
Folgen haben für Zivilisten für Kinder
und das auch lange noch nachdem ein
Krieg vorbei ist MRT wissen jetzt das
Washington welche Überlegungen hinter
diesem umstrittenen Einsatz stecken und
was das für den Krieg bedeutet
die Feuer brennen fast rund um die Uhr
hier kann man sehen warum die USA jetzt
Streu Munition liefern wollen in
scranten Pennsylvania arbeiten sie mit
Hochdruck am neuesten Auftrag 11.000
herkömmliche Artillerie Geschosse pro
Monat aber der Krieg in der Ukraine
lehrt die Lagerbestände der US-Armee
schneller als die produzieren können
sie fertigen 155 mm Granaten für
Horizont heimas Geschütze mit denen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte Stück für
Stück ihr Land zurückerobern sollen die
milliardenschweren Rüstungslieferungen
erzwingen allein in dieser Fabrik 120
Millionen Dollar an neuen Investitionen
wir werden das Geld für neue Maschinen
und neue Fertigungsstraßen einsetzen und
für die Verbesserung der
Arbeitsbedingungen der Infrastruktur der
ganzen Arbeitsumgebung
aber das weitere hochfahren der
Produktion braucht Zeit die herkömmliche
Munition in der Ukraine wird knapp genau
deshalb so heißt es aus dem Weißen Haus
müsste man nun auch Streumunition
liefern
wir wissen das Blindgänger ein Risiko
darstellen aber es gibt auch das massive
Risiko für die Zivilbevölkerung wenn
russische Panzer ukrainische Stellungen
überrollen mehr Territorium erobern und
mehr Zivilisten unterjochen weil die
Ukraine nicht genug Artillerie hat wir
werden die Ukraine niemals in diesem
Konflikt wehrlos zurücklassen Punkt
4,7 Millionen Stück solcher
Streumunition haben die USA 10.000
liegen schon in Europa parat es ist eine
Variante bei der es angeblich nur eine
blindgängerrate von etwas über 2% gäbe
also bei 72 minibomben in jedem Geschoss
während das weniger als zwei Blindgänger
die Ukraine hat sich schriftlich
verpflichtet die Munition nur gegen
russische Stellungen einzusetzen während
die Angreifer vorsätzlich immer wieder
Streu Munition auf zivile Ziele feiern
die angeblicher Alternativlosigkeit
sorgt für zurückhaltende Reaktionen bei
den NATO-Partnern von denen acht die
Ächtung von Streumunition genau wie die
USA ja auch nicht ratifiziert haben
die einzelnen Verbündeten müssen selbst
über die Lieferung von Waffen und
militärischer Ausrüstung an die Ukraine
entscheiden das müssen also die
jeweiligen Regierungen tun nicht die
NATO als Bündnis
Deutschland hatte die Konvention
ebenfalls unterzeichnet für uns ist das
keine Option die Länder die sich dieser
Konvention nicht angeschlossen haben und
dazu gehört neben China Russland die
Ukraine und die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika das habe ich nicht zu
kommentieren die USA wollen die
Streumunition nur so lange liefern bis
es wieder genügend herkömmliche
Geschosse gibt deshalb brennen die Feuer
hier wie gesagt fast rund um die Uhr
ja da müssen wir noch reden mit
Christian Mölling er ist jetzt bei uns
Militärexperte von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik Herr
Mölling guten Abend und willkommen
zurück im heute schon mal hallo guten
Abend was sagt denn das jetzt über die
Verzweiflung in der Ukraine im Westen
was den Verlauf des Krieges angeht dass
man jetzt auf solche Bomben
zurückgreifen will na ich würde nicht
von Verzweiflung reden ich glaube wir
sehen einfach dass die Ukraine wenn sie
ist zurzeit konfrontiert mit einem sehr
effektiven Verteidigungsring mit
Verteidigungsanlagen der russischen
Streitkräfte da ist sehr schwer
reinzukommen oder nur mit hohen
Verlusten und was man jetzt macht ist
tatsächlich im Angesicht der Tatsache
dass auch die Munition das immer weniger
wird man könnte diese Aufgabe auch
mitkommen zu einer Munition realisieren
das ist aber eben immer weniger davon
verfügbar dass man diese Munition die
Streumunition jetzt einsetzt um damit
tatsächlich das Risiko zu reduzieren für
die eigenen Truppen und die
Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit durch diese
verteidigen solange durchzukommen
einfach erhöht damit und wie genau würde
man die dann einsetzen müssen was wäre
denn aus rein militärischer Sicht das
Ziel ja das Ziel ist dass die
infanteriegruppen die sich quasi den
Schützengräben eingegraben haben und
dadurch geschützt werden dass man die
quasi von oben beschießt das heißt die
Granaten werden abgeschossen und zünden
dann über den infantrieb Truppen und
verletzten oder töten diese Truppen dann
das heißt die eine Idee ist tatsächlich
sozusagen die Kampfkraft zu schwächen
und in der Theorie eigentlich auch in
massenanzahl an Verletzten zu erzielen
um damit dann auch das militärische das
medizinische System zu überlasten das
wird in diesem Fall nicht passieren weil
die Russen sich darum ja nicht so
wahnsinnig Scheren ist das nicht ein
Wahnsinn so ein Einsatz für die Ukraine
auf eigenem Territorium auch mit den
potenziellen Spätfolgen die das haben
kann es ist glaube ich genau die
Abwägung die man treffen muss und die
auch der Ukraine obliegt auf der einen
Seite den Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung
sicherzustellen gegen Russland oder auf
der anderen Seite den Schutz gegen die
negativen Folgen solcher Streumunition
nämlich die Blindgänger die halt dann
jetzt irgendwann auf dem Boden liegen
das ist erstmal ein Problem für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte selber die ja
dann vorrücken wollen und auf der
anderen Seite langfristig natürlich dann
für die Zivilbevölkerung das heißt man
muss das Gebiet sperren und reinigen
lassen Sie uns noch kurz über die Folgen
reden diese Streumunition ist ja nicht
ohne Grund per Vertrag von über 100
Nationen weltweit geächtet darunter wir
hier in Deutschland Großbritannien
Frankreich aber eben wie wir gerade
gehört haben nicht die USA nicht
Russland dich die Ukraine was genau
macht diese Munition so furchterregend
wir haben in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
gesehen wo solche Munition zum Einsatz
gekommen ist dass eben keiner mehr auf
einmal weiß wo die Munition verschossen
worden ist und dann die Zivilbevölkerung
zurückgekehrt ist in die Kampfgebiete
und schutzlos in diese quasi dann
Minenfelder hineingelaufen ist und auf
der anderen Seite halt die Räumung
dieser Minen unendlich lange dauert und
das war der Auslöser zu sagen wir
glauben dass diese Waffen nicht mehr
eingesetzt werden sollen das war der das
war der Punkt der den sogenannten
osteprozessen aus der Vertrag
losgetreten hat der Grund ist glaube ich
generell weiterhin richtig wir haben es
hier mit einem der seltenen
Ausnahmefälle zu tun nämlich da wo man
sagen kann es geht nur um die Situation
Soldaten und Soldaten und auch nur wenn
die Ukraine Verantwortung übernimmt und
nach dem Einsatz dieser Waffen das
Kampfgebiet dann auch tatsächlich räumt
bevor sie die Bevölkerung zurückkehrt
trotzdem bleibt doch ein moralisches
Dilemma wie passt das denn jetzt zu den
eigenen auch ukrainischen moralischen
Ansprüchen auch im Krieg wenn man
Munition einsetzt und aus USA solche
Munition liefert die von vielen Staaten
auf der Welt aus guten Gründen geächtet
ist ja ich glaube wir müssen noch mal da
genau hingucken dass viele Staaten sich
auch bewusst dafür entschieden haben
diese Tür zu nutzen dieser Munition
nicht endgültig zu machen dazu gehören
auch Staaten wie Finnland starten wie
Estland und Litauen die für sich
entschieden haben es kann für uns eine
militärische sicherheitspolitische
Situation geben in der wir doch auf
diese Munition zurückgreifen müssen die
Munition ist glaube ich für keinen
westlichen Staat das Mittel der Wahl
aber es kann sein dass man sagt wir
kommen nicht drum herum gerade dann wenn
wir große also Kräfte mäßig quantitativ
große Streitkräfte aufhalten müssen dann
können wir es mit Präzisionswaffen eben
nicht schaffen sondern dann müssen wir
etwas nehmen was ich sage es mal ganz
klar viele Tote auf der Gegenseite
schafft sie glauben also nicht dass der
der Schaden der für die Ukraine auch für
die USA dadurch entstehen könnte für das
eigene Ansehen auch bei den
Unterstützern der Politik der Ukraine
dass der am Ende größer wäre als der
Gewinn auf dem Schlachtfeld ich glaube
das ist jetzt die Aufgabe der einzelnen
Regierung das sehr klar zu erklären und
auch der Regierung die sich dagegen
aussprechen gleichzeitig aber für eine
Unterstützung militärische Unterstützung
der Ukraine sind dass diese Staaten
erklären was denn die praktische
Alternative ist theoretisch lässt sich
darüber ganz viel sagen ganz praktisch
haben wir aber die Situation dass die
Ukraine jetzt eine Lösung braucht
ansonsten wäre die Investition die wir
quasi moralisch aber auch politisch und
militärisch gemacht haben dahin denn die
Ukraine hätte einen größeres Risiko und
würde mit der Offensive die sie jetzt
gestartet hat nicht so weit Vorankommen
wie sie könnte dann gucken wir bitte zum
Schluss noch ganz kurz auf die deutsche
Haltung zur alledem wir haben gerade den
Verteidigungsminister gehört der das
nicht
diskutieren will wenn wir diese
Konvention die Streubomben echtet mal
genau lesen da steht da gleich ganz am
Anfang drin dass sie auch verbietet
ausdrücklich dabei zu helfen Streubomben
einzusetzen heißt das also für
Deutschland dass die Konvention ja
unterzeichnet hat Deutschland muss jetzt
darauf achten dass von deutschen
Haubitzen etwa keine solchen Geschosse
abgeschossen werden können das würde das
wahrscheinlich bedeuten ja genau das ist
eine praktische Umsetzung davon
Deutschland auch die Außenministerin hat
sich ja schon etwas schärfer geäußert
kann wenn es man wenn man diese Normen
nicht verletzen will die mit der mit der
auswirkkonvention verbunden ist dass man
sagt wir wollen diese Waffen nicht dann
muss man auch konsequent sein und sagen
wir dürfen auch dabei nicht unterstützen
muss den Vertrag einhalten ja und dann
kann man nicht einfach sagen wir
kommentieren das nicht ich habe das
nicht zu kommentieren sondern muss sich
da aktiv vor Ort für einsetzen oder ja
man muss sich dafür einsetzen ich glaube
man muss jetzt tatsächlich Sprache
finden wo man die Balance findet
zwischen auf der einen Seite wir haben
eine Verpflichtung und ich glaube man
muss einfach transparent machen dass
unsere Verpflichtung rechtlich ist und
normativ ist und
wo die Grenze ist und was man auf der
anderen Seite den anderen Staaten
zugesteht was ihre Entscheidung ist denn
es ist sowohl die Entscheidung der
Ukraine als auch
der USA zu sagen wir glauben dass der
Einsatz dieser Waffen legal und legitim
ist interessante Analyse auch heute
Abend wieder Christian Mölling
herzlichen Dank dafür
und damit zu unserem nächsten Thema
heute abend es ist heiß draußen und auf
der Tagesordnung stehen lauter heiße
Eisen darunter die Diskussion um ein
heizungsgesetz die alles andere als
beendet ist so gesehen ist es kein
Wunder dass es heute hochherging im
Deutschen Bundestag Ausraster Verwarnung
Ordnungsgeld inklusive im Hohen Haus
liegen am letzten Sitzungstag vor der
Sommerpause einige Nerven blank Patricia
Wiedemeier
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen hallo
[Applaus]
die Kollegen müssen noch zur Abstimmung
also es ist kein Grund sich jetzt
aufzuregen wenn die
Bundestagspräsidentin die Contenance
verliert dann muss es wirklich hoch
hergegangen sein es ist die letzte
Sitzung vor der Sommerpause eigentlich
sollte das sogenannte heizungsgesetz
verabschiedet werden daraus wurde nichts
diskutiert wurde trotzdem und die Union
hätte das gerne in Anwesenheit des
Wirtschaftsministers getan
das geht insbesondere auch darum dass
wir einen Höhepunkt eines indiskutablen
Gesetzgebungsverfahrens erleben und
deshalb zitieren wir den Bundesminister
Habeck lieber Herr frei wie ich ihnen
eben auch persönlich mitgeteilt habe und
wie sie ja auch der offiziellen
Entschuldigung des Bundesministers
entnehmen können hat er ein Termin und
zwar beim Bundesrat das Taktieren der
Union für den SPD-Abgeordneten Michael
schrodi ein ungeheuerlicher Vorgang er
läuft kreuz und quer beleidigt das
Präsidium und wirft der Union vor mit
der AFD gemeinsame Sache zu machen die
Folge eine Ordnungsstrafe von 1000 Euro
. ich teile dem Abgeordneten Michael
schrodi dafür ein Ordnungsgeld die
Nerven liegen hier scheinbar blank kurz
vor der Sommerpause
verbal scharf auch die Debatte
allerdings ging es kaum um die Inhalte
sondern vor allem um das Prozedere sie
haben in den letzten 18 Monaten dieses
Parlament
zum einem Ort der debattenverweigerung
und zu einem Ort des durchpeitschens von
Gesetzen gemacht glauben Sie etwa wir
hätten die Haltung die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ärgern zu wollen nein das tun wir
nicht nein wir haben eine politische
Haltung wir haben eine politische
Haltung die sich fundamental von ihrem
gegründe sozusagen unterscheidet wir
haben nämlich uns verpflichtet uns dem
Klimaschutz zu stellen Klimaschutz hin
oder her auch AFD und Linke beklagen wie
die Ampel das heizungsgesetz
durchpeitschen wollte wir Abgeordneten
sind keine Komparsen die Bundesregierung
hält sich nicht die Abgeordneten was wir
in der letzten Woche gesehen haben war
unsere Demokratie unwürdig meine Damen
und Herren die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat uns die
Schande erspart das hat ignorantes
unausgegorenes und stimmbehaft
zusammengeschusterte gesetzt mit der
Brechstange erzwungen wird zur gleichen
Zeit im Bundesrat hier redet der im
Bundestag vermisste Minister zum
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz übrigens
als eines von vielen Gesetzen der Ampel
das ohne Probleme verabschiedet wurde
doch gefragt wird auch hier nur nach dem
missglückten heizungsgesetz das Gesetz
steht und alle haben das gestern noch
mal bekräftigt also ja der Weg dahin war
dornig und steinig aber er ist
beschritten worden und auch das ein
Beispiel dafür dass sie ein schwieriges
Gesetz jetzt der Verabschiedung sehr
sehr nahe steht die Abgeordneten sie
gehen jetzt in die Sommerpause
wenigstens sie können sich erholen von
nervenaufreibenden Sitzungswochen im
September geht es weiter dann soll das
heizungsgesetz verabschiedet werden
ja kleines selfie noch wir bleiben auch
Moment im Parlament und zwar mit Diana
den Tag und Bundesrat haben heute grünes
Licht für den beschleunigten Bau eines
flüssig Erdgas Terminals auf Rügen
gegeben sie stimmten dafür den Hafen
Mukran als Standort ins LNG
Beschleunigungsgesetz aufzunehmen
dadurch wird ein schnelleres
Genehmigungsverfahren ermöglicht die
Landesregierung von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern lehnt das LG
Terminal ab denn sie befürchtet Schaden
für Umwelt und Tourismus ihr Antrag auf
Anrufung des Vermittlungsausschusses
erhielt allerdings keine Mehrheit
die NATO starten haben sich kurz vor
ihrem Gipfel in Litauen auf ein neues
Ziel für die Verteidigungsausgaben
geeinigt künftig sollen die 31
Bündnismitglieder nach zdf-informationen
mindestens zwei Prozent ihres
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für Verteidigung
ausgeben bisher war lediglich vorgesehen
dass sie sich diesem Richtwert annähern
begründet wird dieser Schritt mit der
Bedrohungslage durch Russland
der ukrainische Präsident selenski ist
zu Gesprächen mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan nach Istanbul
gereist dabei soll es laut silensky um
den anstehenden NATO-Gipfel um
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine und
das getreideabkommen zwischen Kiew und
moskaugehen letzteres soll Mitte des
Monats auslaufen
die niederländische Regierung um
Ministerpräsident rote ist im Streit
über den Kurs in der Asylpolitik
zerbrochen ein letzter Einigungsversuch
der Vierer Koalition ist gescheitert
berichten mehrere Medien die
rechtsliberale Partei um rote hatte
zuvor vorgeschlagen den Zustrom von
Asylsuchenden zu begrenzen zwei
Koalitionspartner weigerten sich dagegen
Flüchtlingsfamilien die Zusammenkunft zu
erschweren
der rassistische Anschlag in Hanau mit
neuen Toten hätte aus Sicht von hessens
Innenminister Beuthen nicht von der
Polizei verhindert werden können das
sagte Beuth bei seiner ersten Aussage
als Zeuge vor dem Hanau
Untersuchungsausschuss in Wiesbaden
euträumte erneut ein dass der Polizei
Notruf in der Nacht des Anschlags im
Februar 2020 überlastet gewesen sei auch
bei der Betreuung der Opferfamilien habe
ist Defizite gegeben
nach der tödlichen Messerattacke in
einem Zug in Brokstedt in
Schleswig-Holstein ist heute der Prozess
gegen den mutmaßlichen Täter eröffnet
worden die Staatsanwaltschaft wirft dem
34-Jährigen Ibrahima zweifachen Mord und
vierfachen versuchten Mord vor der
Palästinenser selbst beteuerte seine
Unschuld im Januar soll er in einem
Regionalzug immer wieder auf mehrere
Fahrgäste eingestochen haben eine
17-Jährige und ihr Freund starben vier
weitere Menschen wurden schwer verletzt
und jetzt der Fall genditzki ein
tragischer Fall beschämend für den
Rechtsstaat manfred genditzki hat einen
Albtraum erlebt verurteilt zu
lebenslanger Haft 13,5 Jahre im
Gefängnis obwohl er unschuldig war das
hat er seit heute schwarz auf weiß in
einem bemerkenswerten Urteil dass der
Justiz eklatantes Versagen bescheinigt
die Richterin heute ist emotional
geworden sie fragt nicht zuletzt in
Richtung ihrer eigenen Kollegen warum
konnte Herr genditzki damals überhaupt
verurteilt werden und sie sagt sichtlich
ergriffen es tut uns wirklich aufrichtig
leid Petra Neubauer und Simon Fanzelt
berichten
es ist viel passiert in den fast 5000
Tagen die Manfred genditzki unschuldig
in Haft saß er ist wieder Vater geworden
in dieser Zeit seine Mutter ist
verstorben
13,5 Jahre einfach verpasst doch als er
das Gericht heute gemeinsam mit seiner
Frau verlässt tut er das als freier Mann
dafür hat sich gelohnt zu kämpfen ja
soll nie eine aufgeben
hinter ihm liegt ein langer steiniger
Weg so sagt es heute die Richterin alles
beginnt in dieser Wohnanlage in
Rottach-Egern im Oktober 2008 wird hier
die 87-Jährige Liselotte Kostüm Tod in
ihrer Badewanne gefunden im
obduktionsprotokoll steht zunächst
nichts von einem Fremdverschulden doch
die Kriminalpolizei glaubt nicht an
einen Unfall und nimmt Manfred
kindnitzki ins Visier der sich als
Hausmeister um die alte Dame gekümmert
hatte er soll sie erschlagen und deine
tränkt haben
trotz vieler Zweifel wird genditzki zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt es wird
mehr als ein Jahrzehnt lang dauern bis
all das widerlegt ist das Gericht geht
im Ergebnis von einem sturzgeschehen aus
von einem Unfall die Geschädigte ist
daher nicht umgebracht worden Manfred
gendetzky ist daher unschuldig in all
den Jahren hält genditzkis Familie zu
ihm auch als er im Revisionsverfahren
erneut verurteilt wird mit
Spendengeldern werden neue Gutachten
finanziert
Computersimulationen legen nahe dass die
Rentnerin gestürzt ist und dass sie
später gestorben sein muss zu einer Zeit
für die kendinski ein Alibi hatte
gemeinsam mit seiner Anwältin erzwingt
er schließlich das
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren
naja das ist doch bedauerlich dass man
zehn Jahre kämpfen muss um so einen
Unrecht aufheben zu lassen
das
darf nicht sein ja das ist wirklich
unzählige Polizeiarbeit geleistet wurde
die dann von den Staatsanwaltschaft und
letztendlich von den Gerichten so
übernommen wird von einer Kumulation von
Fehlleistungen spricht die Richterin
heute
Kontrollmechanismen hätten fast sagt es
tue dem Gericht aufrichtig leid ob das
reicht in der Justiz
schüttelt man sich und verabschiedet
dann den
Angeklagten mit warmen Worten ist ja
alles schön und gut aber letztlich an
der Wurzel gepackt ist das Übel damit
nicht die Vorsitzende Richterin aus dem
zweiten Verfahren ist heute beim
Oberlandesgericht der Staatsanwalt von
damals der ist auch beim
Oberlandesgericht nicht den hat das
alles nicht geschadet
gendetzky stehen prohaft Tag 75 €
Entschädigung zu außerdem kann er etwas
einen Verdienstausfall geltend machen im
Grund zum jungen habe ich nicht 14 Jahre
sind weg also ich werde jetzt keine
Freunde machen
aber sagt Genthin immerhin habe sich ein
Gericht in seinem Fall für die Wahrheit
interessiert zum ersten Mal
die Wahrheit nach 13 Jahren ein Tag aus
dem konkrete Lehrerin zu ziehen wären
jenseits des unschuldig Verurteilten auf
dass sich so etwas nicht wiederholt
so jetzt in der Sendung noch mal Johanna
ja heute direkt auf die Börse wo eine
Tochter Firma das Industriekonzerns
ThyssenKrupp ihr debüge feiert hat
mussera ist auch Technologien
spezialisiert die ist ermöglichen grünen
Wasserstoff zu produzieren Sina meinets
das Unternehmen hat also einen ganz
anderen Fokus als der Stahlriese selbst
genauso ist es nur Zera ging heute mit
dem Slogan we shaple New Era also wir
gestalten die neue Ära an die Börse hier
hinter mir kam es vielleicht sehen und
ThyssenKrupp setzt mit seiner Tochter
Firma damit nicht mehr auf Kohle und
Stahl sondern auf eine grüne Alternative
mit Hilfe von Lucera will mittels
Elektrolyse Wasser in seine Bestandteile
Sauerstoff und Wasserstoff aufgespalten
und mit diesem Wasserstoff können dann
Motoren oder Produktionsanlagen
betrieben werden dieser heutige Sprung
aufs Parkett war erst der zweite
Börsengang in diesem Jahr und durchaus
erfolgreich der Kurs legte rund 18% zu
mit dem erlöst wenn man weiter wachsen
und investieren ja ob es bei nutzerer so
vielversprechend bleibt wird sich zeigen
vergleichbare Unternehmen haben im
vergangenen Jahr erhebliche Kursverluste
erlitten ja du sagst das schon für viele
Wasserstoff Unternehmen sieht es gerade
nicht unbedingt rosig aus woran liegt
das ja das hat verschiedene Gründe
angespannte Lieferketten fehlende
Arbeitskräfte Inflation sowie ein Mangel
an Fördergeldern in vielen Märkten
Bremsen diese grüne Technologie das
erhoffte schnelle Wachstum lässt somit
oftmals auf sich warten außerdem sind
wasserstoffaktien vor allem
Wachstumsaktien und das heißt die
Gewinne liegen häufig in der Zukunft und
sind bei steigenden Zinsen deshalb
weniger wert die wasserstoffnachfrage
ist zwar riesig aber Investoren halten
sich oft zurück viele Projekte kommen
nicht über den anfangsstatus hinaus
vielen Dank Sina nach Frankfurt
die globale Schifffahrt soll
klimafreundlicher werden darauf haben
sich heute die Mitglieder der Welt
schifffahrtsorganisation Emo geeinigt
das 30 soll der Ausstoß von
Treibhausgasen zunächst und mindestens
20 Prozent reduziert werden 2014 sollen
es dann 70 bis 80 Prozent sein das
Vergleichsjahr ist 2008 die
Klimaneutralität soll etwa bis 2050
erreicht werden Klimaschützer äußerten
Kritik an den Beschluss sie hätten sich
strengere Vorgaben gewünscht laut der
IMO ist die internationale Schifffahrt
für rund 3% des weltweiten CO2 Ausstoßes
verantwortlich
in Wimbledon sind mittlerweile alle
deutschen Tennisprofis im Einzel
ausgeschieden bis auf einen Alexander
Zverev der musste sich seinen Sieg heute
gegen den japaner-watanuki hart
erkämpfen morgen trifft er auf den
Italiener berettini das Ziel der Einzug
ins Achtelfinale
zweiter Wettkampftag bei den Finals den
Deutschen Meisterschaften in 18
Sportarten heute unter anderem in der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik und da hat
die 16-jährige Favoritin
ihren Titel verteidigt dann Reifen Ball
Keulen und Bann Band gewann die europa-
und Weltmeisterin vor Margarita kolossow
und Anna schinenko
die morgigen Entscheidungen bei den
Finals sind übrigens live bei uns im ZDF
zu sehen und zwar ab 10:15 Uhr
bei der heutigen Etappe der Tour de
France ging es für die Radprofis von
modemas Song nach
bordeaux-sieger im Massen Sprint nach
170 km wurde Jasper Philipsen für den
Belgier ist es bereits der dritte
Etappen Sieg der deutsche Film Bauhaus
wurde sie da in der Gesamtauswertung
ändert sich nichts Titel Verteidiger
Jonas Wing geworden aus Dänemark bleibt
erster
die unvollendete von Schubert Sinfonie
Nummer 7 in h-Moll lässt sich nicht mehr
vollenden auch nicht wenn 200
Schülerinnen und Schüler alles geben
aber sie bietet großartige Möglichkeiten
einen eigenen Zugang zu finden zur Welt
der klassischen Musik für eben diese 200
Jungen Hamburgerinnen und Hamburger
kommt noch eine ganze Reihe von
ungewöhnlichen Veranstaltungsorten dazu
und schon sind wir jetzt mit Sarah
wasaska beim tonali Festival
[Musik]
ein Kreuzfahrtterminal wird zum
Konzertsaal Schuberts die unvollendete
sieben Mal gibt es sie dieser Tage in
Hamburg zu hören jedes Mal an einem
anderen meist ungewöhnlichen Ort und
jedes mal ganz anders interpretiert
das besondere bei diesem Festival sind
nicht nur professionelle Jungmusiker
dabei sondern auch rund 200 Schüler aus
der ganzen Stadt
wie diese Jugendlichen von einer
weiterführenden Schule in Eidelstedt
selbst musizieren Klassik hören für
viele eine ganz neue Erfahrung ich
persönlich habe zum ersten Mal ein
Orchester gehört und das war wirklich
ein sehr schönes Moment es war traumhaft
es war einfach nur noch genießen und
diesen Moment spüren und ins Herz
einschließen ganz besonders fand ich an
den Projekt ähm also richtig die
richtigen Instrumente zu sehen wie
eigentlich so eine Musik entsteht man
hörte ja man meistens nur über Aufnahmen
aber mal live so was zu hören fand ich
sehr besonderes
Generalprobe im Desi einem
Forschungszentrum für Quantenphysik hier
findet am Abend ihre Aufführung statt
für die meisten ist es der erste große
Auftritt wenn man dann auf der Bühne ist
dann das herzklopft und dann steht man
da vor vielen Leuten dann denkt man sich
nur so ich mache das jetzt das ist
einfach magisch wir können den Kindern
so Sachen zeigen oder naheling die Sie
wahrscheinlich sonst nie in ihrem Leben
gemacht hatten und das macht mir
eigentlich die größte Freude die
Gesichter zu sehen die dieses Effekt
[Musik]
der jungen Generation eine Bühne bieten
dahinter steht die Kultur und
Bildungsinitiative tornadi für den
Gründer ist das Projekt eine
Herzensangelegenheit
und wo wir diese Bühne aufmachen kann
dann halt auch wer auch immer bisher
Angst hatte dahin zu kommen mal hin und
dadurch nähern sich zwei Sphären an und
das ist gesellschaftlich unglaublich
spannend und dient dem Zusammenhalt und
um dem geht es uns ganz maßgeblich
dafür gehen sie auch in die Stadtteile
animieren Hamburgs Bewohner zum
Mitmachen
[Musik]
die Jugend die Gesellschaft einbeziehen
klassische Musik und Konzerte neu denken
darum geht es bei diesem Festival im
Kreuzfahrtterminal heißt das für das
Publikum auch ganz nah dran sein
eine gute Nachricht noch und ein
wichtiger Hinweis für alle in und um
Hamburg das Abschlusskonzert ist am
Sonntag in der Elbphilharmonie
und damit sagen wir tschüss für heute
und gern bis morgen ja und gegen 0:10
gibt es da noch unser heute journal
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann
angenehmer
[Musik]
ja guten Abend dieses Wochenende
schwitzen wir bei Sommer pur übrigens
ist es in ganz Europa zur Zeit sehr warm
ob es von 15 Grad und mehr auf Island
und Nordskandinavien bis hin zu den 40
Grad die wir dann morgen in Spanien
erreichen in Nordafrika gibt es sogar 45
Grad und mehr und von hier kommt jetzt
auch die heiße Luft die zwischen hoch
Evi und tief Quentin zu uns
transportiert wird die wollten hier über
Frankreich die zeigen uns da hat sich
aber noch mal eine kleine Störung
gebildet und die bringt uns heute Nacht
vom Südwesten bis in die Mitte noch mal
ein paar Wolken eventuell greift doch
mal ein Schauer oder ein Gewitter von
Frankreich auf den Südwesten über sonst
ist das sternenklar die Wetter singen
meist auch noch erfrischende 14 bis 10
Grad in den Ballungsgebieten westlich
des Rheins und an der See geht's aber
schon nicht mehr unter 19 bis 17 Grad
und morgen ist es dann fast überall 30
Grad heiß und mehr es geht bisschen zu
35 Grad im Westen und im Südwesten hier
gibt es auch eine starke Wärmebelastung
etwas erträglicher ist es in höheren
Lagen und an der See bei auflandigem
östlichen Wind dazu beginnt der Tag
morgen mit viel Sonne zur Erinnerung
mittags gibt es ja die intensivste
Strahlung da wird am meisten Sonnencreme
gebraucht aber die höchsten Temperaturen
die erreichen wir erst am späten
Nachmittag frühen Abend und so
entwickeln sich dann neben ein paar mehr
Quellwolken im Südwesten einzelne
Hitzegewitter aufgepasst heißt es dann
aber am Sonntag mit Unwettern in der
Westhälfte im Osten noch sonnig starke
bewerbebelastung bei bis 37 Grad und
auch in der neuen Woche gibt es noch
Gewitter von Nordwesten wird etwas
weniger warm im Osten und im Süden
bleibt es aber heiß